so next up will be talking journalist a
moderating is Elizabeth wookie she's a
business and technology reporter whose
work has been published in Business Week
Forbes and money magazines she's also
the author of the book the smartphone
anatomy of an industry and one of the
leaders of another Yale cig the Yale
alumni journalism Association we also
have Kevin Delaney who is the
editor-in-chief and co-president of
quartz which is a global business news
site from Atlantic media it launched in
2012 and today reaches over 10 million
unique visitors each month previously
kevin was a reporter at The Wall Street
Journal and then the managing editor of
wsj com and he championed efforts there
to greatly expand the journals online
readership he was named a business or
deepest business journalist of 2013 by
the talking biz news media website we
also have Aaron Pettigrew who is the
chief strategy officer at Gawker Media
since joining the company in 2005 she
has led grown and run multiple teams
that helped to scale it's news stories
and advertising products from small
local blogs to a collection of
international properties that reach more
than 125 million people today she leads
product development and strategic
planning of the company's technology
initiatives and she was the recipient of
the digital media Leadership Award so I
will now turn it over to Elizabeth thank
you thanks Elina so we've been talking
about the transforming effects of
Technology all day and this is a topic
that's especially relevant to journalism
as a Kevin pointed out to me this week
has been full of news about digital
media transformations and new products
on Monday Politico launched a Europe
politics ight politically you on the
same day the South China Morning Post
which is Hong Kong's largest
english-language newspaper launched an
international edition which is meant to
be a portal about China news for
international readers and then on
Tuesday both the Atlantic and the Wall
Street Journal
unveiled major website redesigns so I
think you know this week has probably
been busier than most but it's certainly
representative of the constant evolution
of the digital media landscape so let's
start by putting a sort of a personal
lens on today's topic of transforming
journalism if you could both talk about
the changes you've observed in digital
media since you started your own career
so within the context of your careers
and that can be editorial and or
business changes sure when I i started
at Gawker Media in 2005 and at the time
I think the big question was can you do
news on the internet at all is that
something that's going to work is that
something that's commercially viable is
that something that will succeed and
kind of erode at print journalism or is
that just something that's going to live
in a silo on the side and so over the
last 10 years that I've been at the
company we solved that problem and the
answer is that yes digital is going to
sort of become a thing on its own news
will survive and be viable through the
online space and no longer sort of print
the kind of monolith that it was in the
past it's been a lot of evolution and I
think the technology that's been the
undercurrent throughout has really seen
a lot of change as well I for me one of
the funniest things that when I joined
the company gizmodo our technology title
was covering gadgets like mp3 players
and like even sort of you know like
really old school computers and laptops
and now it's obviously wearable devices
and drones and things like that you can
just see the evolution of technology
sort of through our content as well
which has been fascinating so the thread
for me in journalism has been kind of
tinkering in experimenting so I was
class of 94 in styles as editor-in-chief
of The Herald and at that moment desktop
publishing was coming in so we were used
in McIntosh you know sort of
revolutionized access to actually
desktop publishing and so you know
starting a 90 when i arrived at yale we
were using the first versions of
Photoshop and pagemaker we uploaded the
herald to buy ftp to mosaic and these
things that are preceded the web as we
as we use it today and was really
excited
that time was actually using the
technology that was just kind of
emerging at Yale to to accompany
journalism and do things that were that
were creative and exciting and were
previously unaccessible so the so the
last you know serve zoom for 20 years I
went I left yell I worked in television
which was sort of like the new media of
the 90s and then wound up at the at the
wall street journal as a technology
correspondence I was based in San
Francisco and at some point the news was
just you know incredibly depressing for
the journalism industry to the point
where you had to ask like am I going to
have any career at 20 years from now and
in fact if you look at the chart of the
number of journalists employed in the
United States it's incredibly bleak so
it goes you know from the high point in
the 70s or 80s whenever it in it is and
it's a sort of endless decline from
there and so in 2008 I came back to work
on wsj.com with this sort of feeling
that we needed to save journalism and
that serves superficial aggregation and
SEO maximization was actually something
that traditional news organizations need
to be better about or at least be
actively thinking about but that
ultimately there was something that went
beyond that journalistically that was a
value to all of us and actually did have
a possible thriving future online and so
so to fast forward three a little bit
more three years ago I left the Wall
Street Journal and joined the company
that owns the Atlantic and that was
precisely are our venture starting from
zero to create a news organization one
that is journalistic but also digital
and and figure out if we could make this
viable in terms of attracting a
readership but also in terms of creating
a business that's that's ultimately
profitable so let's tackle the big
question for digital journalism which i
think is the question of sustainability
meaning financial viability given that
the traditional journalism business
model of you know selling subscriptions
to readers
and a small number of high-priced ads
the advertisers is no longer as
effective or relevant online it seems
that for publishers today there is sort
of no one revenue strategy it's about
drawing upon a number of different
revenue streams trying a combination of
things so I was wondering if you two
could talk about what you've found what
works what hasn't in terms of financial
sustainability for journalism online and
also how you decided on the combination
of revenue streams you're currently
using yeah so we um we started out being
very ad supported and kind of said let's
translate everything that we know about
traditional media to the web ok that's
an ad-supported business it's major sort
of blue-chip clients that are buying
through ad agencies and we went out and
did that and we said ok we can put that
online and so when I first started at
the company it was literally figuring
out how to get like jpg banners from you
know Stoli vodka onto the site and that
in itself at that time was actually a
difficult thing to do but it was
promising because there were brands that
were interested in spending but at that
time I was very experimental and so as
you know the years have passed we've
seen that that translation of the
traditional advertising business has
come online entirely I think the share
is still you know it's still growing
over time but the growth rate is slowed
because it's basically sort of reached a
level of penetration online that it's
pretty healthy but now we're at a point
where that ad business isn't supporting
every single expense that many of these
media companies have and so revenue
diversification has become like an
enormous part of many sort of business
and sales side organizations at media
companies our business at Gawker is
roughly seventy-five percent kind of
traditional online advertising and in
twenty-five percent sort of experimental
revenue streams that run from e-commerce
through affiliate marketing and kind of
offers for products to readers to
international licensing partnerships to
actually licensing the content that we
produce to a variety of different
commercial constituents all of those
explorations have been really important
and interesting to us it's basically
come down to the web gives you a lot
more options in terms of revenue model
so we look at the massive audience we've
accrued and say okay we're the natural
sort of fits between what is the
audience looking for information
interesting things about products where
our commercial partners seeing like a
natural fit with our audience and where
can we align those better through kind
of new business models a lot of what
we're doing in that 25% kind of area we
expect to grow and kind of challenge the
ad business that we have now for
something closer to parity between sort
of a mix of new and healthy streams and
kind of the traditional business that
supported a lot of big consumer media in
the past and by the way Aaron didn't
mention this but I believe she built up
the affiliate marketing business at
Gawker Media into a multi-million dollar
business um she also doesn't really good
pretty impressive yeah so um so I think
the good news is served three years in
with quartz the good news is that
actually media is a sustainable and
profitable or can be your profitable
business the back of the envelope
business plan for quartz very very
approximate was that the the annual
advertising revenue for the economist
and the financial times together was
five hundred million dollars a year and
that most of that was print but you
could make a sort of bet that a lot of
that was going to migrate online and
that if we could get just five percent
five percent of something seems like a
small amount if we get five percent of
an existing amount of money that people
were spending to spend them on a digital
high quality global media organization
that's speaking to business
professionals around the world that
seemed like a pretty doable thing and we
knew that we could do that on a cost
basis with a cost structure because
we're starting from scratch that
actually would allow us to be profitable
we're only partway down that road but
the the first part of this voyage it
confirms our initial instincts about the
potential there so our our revenue is
primarily advertising we do some events
the Atlantic has a super strong events
business and we've benefited from they
have the Aspen ideas festival and other
things that they they that are
significant portion of revenue to
support the enterprise and support their
journalism and and the work that erin
has done at Gawker is really
industry-leading and looking for other
revenue sources which is something we're
interested in doing but there is really
there the opportunity just on
advertising revenue
loan is really significant quartz has
had over 100 advertisers at this point
all of them brands that you guys with no
banks and car makers and things like
that we have close to a ninety percent
renewal rate so there is a sort of
vibrant market for for this sort of this
sort of advertising part of the context
for this question is that if you're a
traditional news organization and you
have a building and you have bureaus
around the world and you have all of the
printing infrastructure and all of these
capital investments that these
organizations are sustaining this is a
really difficult time and they give the
New York Times and others a ton of
credit for for being much more
experimental than they have ever been
much more digitally thinking but they're
still part of a transitional moment
where it's it's less like a media and
audience moment it's more like an
economic business case economic model
moment where they have to migrate from
one there's very different than what
ultimately most people I think believe
the media has come in and that's why the
New York Times is like doing great but
you know there every year at these big
news organizations they're they're quite
or not so quiet buyouts and layoffs and
and other sort of symptoms of the
difficulty of making that economic
adjustment think a lot of us I was just
going to piggyback on that a lot of us
spend a lot of time last year reading
the New York Times innovation report so
everybody in media as soon as this thing
came out it was like 80 pages that were
put together to show how the New York
Times could transition to an effective
digital business on like a cost basis
and revenue basis and all these
different things I think we all
circulated that around it was a big
moment where it made me really glad to
be in kind of a pure-play digital
business not have to go through that
transition that you're describing it's
hard now there was a question earlier
today about native advertising and I
thought we should take a minute and talk
about that since these are two websites
that are doing native advertising and I
think you know doing it very
successfully so I think one of the
interesting questions there is sort of
the effectiveness of native ads compared
to a more traditional display ad in
terms of both the outcomes advertisers
are looking for so whether it's brand
lift or engagement or whatnot and then
also in terms of the higher rate
that you're able to charge advertisers
for them yeah so we actually started
experimenting with native advertising
before it even had that moniker we call
something a sponsored post back and I
think it's 2009 or 2010 and said the
currency that we communicate with our
audience in is actually the blog post
what if we actually translated
advertising from the banner into a blog
post and started writing sponsored copy
and those of you who have spent time in
media also know that this isn't really
even an innovation magazines have been
doing paid editorial radios been doing
paid spots for a long time but we
started this quite a while ago and the
idea was that we could have a much more
quality kind of relationship with the
consumer over sort of a written piece of
content and that proved to be the case
so over the last six seven years we've
grown that business quite a bit to where
we now have kind of two channels of it
there's a an awareness based effort so
big branded content programs for major
advertisers that are all about getting
brand lift for specific programs through
awareness based posts and then we have
kind of a direct response version of
that same program which is incentivized
on a sort of a cost per action basis or
performance based pricing and that
actually sells products to the
readership through content again marked
is sponsored but gives us an opportunity
to kind of play with that full funnel
both of those we think are more
effective than the standard banner
advertising but it's not the case that
they're in Tyler displacing we often see
that these things get bundled into a
kind of bouquet of offerings for the
same advertiser that's looking to
communicate a variety of different
messages at a variety of different
moments through a variety of different
products to our rather large audience so
I don't think I don't think digital
media is Aaron said gets credit for
inventing native content when you open
the New York Times some state some days
and it says special advertising section
and the headline of the article is
people in Russia are happier than
anywhere else in the world you as a
reader of the New York Times understand
that that is not something that the New
York Times Moscow bureau chief is
written presumably so it's a similar
thing with the important thing there are
two important principles for that we
believe one is that you never try and
fool the reader so there's extensive
labeling at every point where reader
could
we interact with this content the second
thing is that the editorial staff should
have zero involvement with this and so
as editor-in-chief I actually sees none
of the sponsor content until it's on the
site and other readers presumably have
seen it already it is a growing area
that's an area of intent advertiser
interest I don't know the sort of data
on the amount of engagement I do I can
recount one short anecdote which is that
i was i was in Davos this winter and I
was I was the only person there for
quartz and I was frantically trying to
cover it and get over jet lag and and I
woke up in a haze one morning and was
looking at our traffic and there's this
Pope there's this headline in our
heartbeat system which kind of monitors
the real-time traffic and it was Davos
highlights from day two and I looked at
this and i was thinking like did i write
that and just not remember it and it
turns out that we had a bank that was
sponsoring sponsored content and what
they were doing is actually paying
someone to write highlights of
abdallah's and it turns out that that
post was actually more popular on our
site that then you know unfortunately
anything that I had written in the
previous 40 48 hours so I I'm at a
distance from it but I can tell you that
I observe that people do read this stuff
particularly when it when it has some
informational value I think to echo that
most of the organizations that are
succeeding with this have entirely
insulated kind of that sponsored content
native advertising production from the
editorial teams and all for the best
it's been pretty clean I think and
that's what's allowed it to see success
so by the way if any of you are
wondering whether these business
strategies are successful on Gawker
Media is profitable and quartz is still
an investment mode because it's only two
and a half years old keep that in mind
so one the revenue stream we didn't talk
about but which I think will become
really relevant in the near future is
this idea of Facebook allowing
publishers allowing Facebook to host
their content directly on facebook site
again this question came up briefly this
morning with the Henry Blodgett
presentation and Henry basically said as
a digital publisher he was okay with the
idea what I wanted to run this hot topic
past the both of you and see I do think
certainly so again this is a story that
the New York Times broke about a month
ago it's about having instead of
clicking through to a story on Facebook
you're going to be able to read the
entire article on facebook you will sort
of stay within the Facebook ecosystem
and I think it's pretty clear that then
I'll just stand here for a while so I
think it's pretty clear that that makes
sense for facebook and for facebook
users but to get the perspective of from
a digital publisher does that make
business sense for you to partner with
facebook on that so i think you know a
digital publisher or any publisher for
that matter holds with two things in
really high regard in terms of
relationships one is the publishers
relationship with its audience its
readership and the other is the
publishers relationship with its
commercial partners or it's advertisers
I think it's unclear for me right now
kind of where Facebook's rumored
publisher partnership program is going
to how it will I guess affect those
relationships that publishers hold
really near and dear we've seen a lot
from the way that Facebook has become
such an immense traffic channel for
publishers that they they are kind of
coming in and taking a little bit of
that reader relationship away from the
publisher or kind of becoming an
intermediary for it Facebook has not
really announced what it might offer as
far as the advertising share that might
be available and things like that so
really anxious to see kind of how the
product actually rolls out how it looks
to preserve those relationships for
readers and for advertisers for the
publisher because those are going to
because sort of the major points of
concern for any publisher that's reached
a level of size that it really has those
relationships that it it's concerned
about protecting so it'll be interesting
to watch I think you know I think
ultimately what our goal is is to have
our content wherever readers are and if
our readers are on Facebook and this is
somehow a better experience for them
that's something that we probably should
be open to all ready quartz content is
available on Flipboard in google
newsstand use which you speak called
currents and their bunch of places where
you can actually get our content we're
fine with that particularly if his Erin
said the conditions are good for us
being able to make some revenue from it
to actually pay for our journalists to
make our to to grow our business and so
that's a that's a question mark about
Facebook but in general I think
publishers are really required to feel
comfortable having their content live
off off their site there's you know
there are some legitimate questions that
this raises about the extent to which
publishers are doing this exclusively
the extent to which they lose control
well over over reaching or readership
and you know there's this is for legal
and First Amendment scholars to debate
but there are questions about the
pressures that governments could bring
to bear on Facebook in terms of
distributing content in their countries
or Facebook has enforce certain
standards around nudity and other
societal norms that it could effectively
apply to journalistic content which may
or may not be consistent with how how
newspapers or news organizations think
think today so I think that's a I think
that's an interesting question the last
thing I would tell you is that a lot of
the discussion around Facebook assumes
that Facebook is the only platform that
exists on the planet and and I don't
think that's true I mean they're they're
clearly the one that is most important
for media organizations right now but
particularly as you think about mobile
phones and the apps and the operating
systems and you can very quickly come up
with it with a at least a few other
platforms that could apply competitive
pressure to Facebook in how they treat
content that ultimately could could be
good for publishers as a result so today
I'm a couple of the different panels and
discussions have touched upon the
business importance of tracking data and
mining data and in journalism I think
the focus used to be on page views and
then it for the most part went to unique
visitors and now there's some attention
being paid towards various measures of
reader engagement however you measure it
so for instance I think BuzzFeed looks
at social shares so how much is being
shared to social networks and given this
is a very tech centric crowd I think
they'd be interested in hearing both of
you talk about the metrics you pay
attention to you at your websites and
how you define success in relation to
those metrics yeah so for us data is
different across different parts of the
organization's you know on the business
side people are very concerned about
engagement as you describe the
ad online ad universe has really turned
toward view ability as an understanding
of kind of defrauding of online
advertising art people actually seeing
at how much time are they spending with
them are they kind of if it's a video
playing through the entirety of the
video or some portion of it it's enough
to be considered a true view that would
be sort of like the focus on the ad side
of the business on the technology side
of the business there's a lot of focus
on any kind of any kind of metric we can
learn more about but time spent and
engagement is definitely a heightened
sense of importance right now but on the
editorial side of the business we've
gone through a few arcs we went from
pageviews just as you described where
you know post getting 100,000 500,000 a
million pageviews was seen as a record
moment and I was a very exciting for
everybody in signaled success for the
writers then came unique visitors which
was a way to sort of like bring
pageviews into an understanding of
people and that was something that led
to I think a bit of sensationalism a bit
of pandering toward just attracting a
new eyeball at every single moment so
our editorial staff has moved to
something new and kind of skipped past
engagement for right now away from sort
of quantity metrics and toward a quality
metrics so they've instituted something
that they call a story bonus and done
away with in sanitization on sort of a
quantity based metric like a unique or
page view so now each site submit
stories that they think are really
representative of our organizations kind
of journalistic ideals and those are
vetted at the end of each month and then
there's sort of a discussion about which
stories best represent the type of
journalism that we want to be creating
and that for us was a reaction to what
we saw happening and so many of our
competitors who were turning toward a
more lower kind of common denominator
type of content in order to get traffic
from facebook and to get traffic from
these places that were really doing a
lot of clickbait games so story bonus
for us has been a way to kind of return
to quality we don't know what that's
going to do to you know reach numbers in
the long term so it's a risk that we're
taking but we think it's important to
kind of say hold on wait a minute
content was sort of moving down in
quality we need to return to a high kind
of standard for that content quality and
kind of see what that does for the
business and hope that if we're true to
the reader with a really good story that
all else will kind of prevail
in the end we'll see what happens and I
think Gawker is also investing more and
investigative reporting again writer
scoops and yes we've spent a lot of time
kind of going back to basics on what
what does it mean to still tell a story
to a reader it's we've created kind of a
an editorial services group that's
actually you know staff with
investigative reporting that is focused
on quality and providing support to
writers with more kind of graphic and
video and an illustration all these
types of things to really focus on
telling better stories every day so I so
our use of data I think it's pretty
similar in that it's just totally
pervasive in the organization from the
advertising sales to technologies to the
journalists and so they're there our
approach is very similar one thing I
just piggybacking on what Aaron said one
thing that's really interesting is that
when you look at the data about what
people read we talk about it
conceptually as a curve and the idea
it's a sort of u-shaped curve and it
turns out what people read is sort of on
the ends of the curve and on the sort of
Y axis is success and then on the x-axis
is is ambition length that sort of thing
and so to be more specific people read
thinks that are short focused shareable
visual in the flow of the news in we
think about things that are under 500
words they often contain charts we
produce lots of charts on quartz those
are those are really widely read it
makes sense in particular given the
amount of time people spend reading news
on their phones but something that's
very easily digested and shared and it's
sort of clear what it's about and why
you should be reading is something that
would be popular but actually it turns
out that on the other end of the curve
there is an enormous readership for for
in-depth ambitious long-form journalism
where there's a payoff for the reader in
terms of narrative analysis reporting
and it turns out that those articles
which you know often are thousands of
words long are actually just as popular
as the short sort of socially enabled
focused things that are written on the
news a really good example this is
the cover stories of the Atlantic so the
Atlantic has these cover stories that
are often about 10,000 words long the
recent one was about Isis 10,000 word
pretty wonky story the case for
reparations by tanahashi coats 10,000
words these stories are among the most
popular stories among across the company
and it turns out that when you look at
the data readers the the number of
visits actually exceed the number of
visitors which tells you that people
actually are starting to read the story
it's 10,000 words long so this is like
half an hour commitment or something to
read it but they're actually coming back
and finishing the story or at least
reading more of it and by the way if
you're wondering how long of 400-500
word story is as a reporter I'm
typically writing 800 to 1,200 word
stories so we're talking about stories
that are about half the length at quartz
compared to a sort of traditional
business media article all right there
more efficient to read we're looking
after our readers deficiency so one
aspect of the of the digital journalism
business I think sometimes gets
overlooked is a technology and design so
it's hoping to talk about are the
importance of these content management
systems or publishing platforms and
whether you think that digital
publishers digital media companies need
to be technology companies as well sort
of how important it is to have
technology embedded into all the aspects
of your business and how you have
managed to do that at your companies
yeah when I came to Gawker in 2005 that
was the age of there were a couple of
different sort of consumer level
publishing platforms available there was
like blogger wordpress movable type we
actually started the business on movable
type and we just started using this
off-the-shelf CMS to produce our
business it quickly became apparent that
we needed a level of customization sort
of multiple site management multiple
author management etc that just wasn't
available from the off-the-shelf product
so we as many sort of news organizations
did started to build a homegrown CMS at
the time not ended up being
decision that we felt was part of I
would say like a competitive advantage
for us it allowed us to get news out
very quickly to iterate on kind of the
way that we format and deliver news to
the reader to we started very early with
building a comment system that was
integrated into our actual CMS where as
many of the comment systems now are
separate sort of embed that you kind of
wrap into a CMS we've kind of been
working for a long time on building a
system that is specifically aimed at
meeting our own needs both the writer
side and the reader side and we view
that is really important to our specific
business I think we're at a level of
scale where where we do need that and
that is important for us that also gives
us some sense of the future of like what
owning the distribution to our
readership is going to look like as we
talk about things like Facebook
potentially creating a publishing
platform or publishing environment you
start to realize how having made an
investment in technology for your own
publishing starts to be very critical to
understanding where that relationship
with the reader and the publisher is
going to end up so for us we intend to
be very very bullish on building our own
platform continuing kind of this arc of
technology in house that we've had for a
long time and I think it's almost still
nascent in our organization i think we
anticipate that getting a lot bigger and
potentially being of benefit to other
publishers in the future lots of future
plans kind of on our road map for that
right so the potential possibly in the
future too for other news organizations
to license kinjo the platform that or
for a consumer to maybe you know spend a
bit of time creating the news on our
platform and benefit from a shared
ecosystem of a lot of readers who are
already there looking for news and then
at quartz I mean I think have if you've
looked at quartz you'll notice the it's
sort of now there are all these copycats
trying to do the infinite scrolling
effect and sir there's this amazing
hybrid of a web app
acting like a nap but actually
technically a website so well so
technology has been really important
we're still a relatively small
organization we have but we have
probably close to 15 developers and four
designers working on the product and
advertising which relative to our size
is way off the scale for a media
organization and it won and we've you
know it's exactly what you'd expect like
we view technology and design as you
know arguably more important than the
dated Dave journalism to our to our
ultimate success and should probably
take that back because we have a bunch
of journalists who think what they're
doing is most please please don't tweet
that out yet I need to have a staff
conference to calm everybody everyone is
equally important at quartz the
developers the advertising sales the
journalists the designers and but it's
like it's critical I'm the one things
we've done structurally that are really
important is the journalists and the
developers sit next to each other in the
newsroom the designers they sit back to
back we have them all sort of scattered
the developers and the journals
scattered around it turns out that there
are advantages to having the developers
a little more concentrated but they're
all in the same space my previous
experience was that the developers that
I worked most closely with many of them
were located in another state and so
that actually there in New Jersey and
that's just not ideal for like
creativity and brainstorming like
figuring out what the future of business
which is the absolute need of of media
organizations now there's one other
incredibly powerful thing that happens
when you do this which is that you start
creating tools that change the form and
and accelerate the journalism that
you're able to do so we very early on
created this thing which we called chart
builder and what it is is it's a really
simple web-based tool that our
journalists use to create charts we put
this in their hands we built this
ourselves it's much less complicated or
sophisticated than anything that
microsoft offers you or probably even
Google Docs but it enables you to make a
really pretty chart in about two minutes
and all of our journalists do that so
last year our staff of journals was
probably in the range of like 20
reporters on average to the
of the year they themselves produce 30
over 3,800 charts using this tool called
chart builder in a traditional just sort
of signal how significant this is in a
traditional news organization I as a
reporter we wrote hundreds and hundreds
of articles for The Wall Street Journal
we have to go an email or walk over and
request a charred and you know is a much
more kind of industrial manufacturing
process them I just sort of making this
myself so we actually we open source
chart builder it's available on github
and is used by a lot of these news
organizations that have their own
graphic service department but if we
didn't have developers and journals
sitting together kind of picking this
out that would that that would not have
happened and so we touched Kevin touched
a little bit about the experience of
reading on mobile when he was talking
about you know why courts articles are a
little shorter than you might see
another business publications but let's
do sort of a deeper dive into mobile I
think people probably be interested in
what you've observed in terms of how
people read on mobile devices and how
you have you know tweaked your your
websites to look really good on mobile
to be a great reading experience on
mobile whether that's you know redesigns
or sort of journalistic training yeah I
think mobile everyone everyone knows
it's much smaller so the reader values
is simpler more direct experience and so
we've kind of taken that as our mantra
and we just have a very simple you know
reverse chronological listing of every
post with enough of an excerpting sort
of an image thumbnail to give a clue to
what the post might be about to allow
you to have that kind of snackable
reading experience but to allow you to
tap in and actually you know read the
entire post I think that's pretty
standard but simplicity has been kind of
the guiding goal there things you start
to discover about mobile that that guide
other design directions so for instance
we just did kind of an experiment on
what does it mean to the reader to
launch a new window when opening a link
and so on desktop we found there was
virtually no difference in sort of the
users preference they were kind of okay
with a force new window or they you know
would be fine opening in the same window
but on mobile that was an extremely
unpleasant want new window
to be like forced popped on mobile and
Sunni that's a piece of data you take
back and kind of incorporate into what
you're building I think we want to have
the most sort of pleasant easy
accessible experience we're entirely
mobile web right now so we've basically
taken a very responsive design approach
what you get on the desktop is very
similar to what you got on mobile just a
very simple stream want to make it very
easy accessible free open to anyone
roughly half of our readers come in on
mobile and tablet devices which is
pretty much the industry norm and I
think the most valuable thing you can do
on mobile is to have your site load
really fast and to get rid of anything
that is not of utility on the screen to
the vast majority of your readers and so
what we've done is worked a ton on the
performance of just getting it to load
fast load fast and actually extend
removing buttons and in frames and when
you're reading a court story basically
all you see is the text of the story
there's no other framing or are we don't
force our own share buttons because we
know that Apple has really nice share
buttons and most people use anyway so
that's sort of the primary thing that
we've done simplify and get it to the
readers as fast as possible so as of I
guess pretty much right now there's a
new mobile screen that digital
publishers can target and design for and
that's the you know the very small that
the SmartWatch the Apple watch screen so
i was wondering this is this is more
future forward but to what extent are
you looking at how you want your reading
experience to be on you know this 1.5
inch smart widescreen the tiniest screen
in the world I think you know apples
marketing their Apple watch is the most
personal device and I think that's how
you have to think about it for news as
well how can you as a news publisher
deliver a very very personal experience
that's enough to interrupt or sort of
give access to on something that's
living on your wrist I don't think we
know the answer to that yet i think we
produce thousands of articles per day we
would need to work on figuring out you
know what
user specifically wants to see how we
might kind of update them that that
content is available things like that I
think we'd be looking toward how can we
create a very personal news experience
from what is now a pretty sort of like
you know choose your own menu of
thousands of different things to read so
we would need to do quite a bit of
curation for that reader I would think
but we're kind of not there yet the
watch has yet to ship yeah i agree i
think the barrier is really high one of
it we have all these news publishers
that are there watch apps that they're
launching and the reality is that users
of the watch are going to turn off the
notifications on their watch for
virtually every single one of these and
my understanding from talking to a
developer about this is it's a binary
thing so you can't say I'd like one
notification a day from this annoying
news watch app that is pinging my wrist
every 10 minutes you actually have to
turn it it's either on or off and so
you're turning over control for what's
effectively a simulated physical tap on
your body to a news organization to to
interrupt whatever you're doing via this
experience so i don't i agree with air
and i'm not sure how this is going to
end up i'm not actually that one
attitude in the face of this could be
despairing like you know the window for
for news organizations to reach their
readership has just shrunk to the size
of a lot and one notification a day that
a user might conceivably tolerate I
actually don't that doesn't seem to be
like the like least narrow people do
actually you know people are reading
more news than ever and that's not going
to suddenly turn off because they have a
five-hundred-dollar or more Apple device
strapped to their with risks I think
what it means is that phones are going
to continue being large and people are
going to read news on them and that's
the platform that is ultimately the
platform that publishers need to focus
on above anything else right so i think
i think the New York Times CNN and The
Wall Street Journal at least those NPR
also have apple watch apps at launch
this will be interesting to see how how
popular those apps actually are
and also whether people click through to
the story to read on their iPhone or
actually read the whole article on their
watch I guess that's that's yet to be
seen so one thing we haven't talked
about yet but which I would like to is
video because we are seeing that sort of
a trend amongst digital publishers to
invest more in video so I think BuzzFeed
Vice vox media have all either started
entertainment division some are based in
LA or they sort of beefed up their their
video investments in general some of
them are also looking towards longer
form video content but both Gawker Media
and courts are also investing more in
video and I think both of you sort of
had recent video milestones so if you
could sort of talk about the value of
video for sites like yours yeah I think
it's clear that readers or consumers if
you will are really looking toward video
is something that they want to spend
time with I find it's a very captive
experience so you have to have something
that's worth spending time with them and
that's worth putting everything that
you're doing down and kind of you know
really take the reader's attention and
give them sort of that two minutes or 30
seconds or whatever it is we've been
watching the investment across the
industry and video and wanted to make
sure that what we did would be sort of
efficient and profitable and all of
those things and so instead of investing
and you know hiring a bunch of big TV
execs to go and produce you know shows
that the level of production is you
might see at a cable channel we're
taking you know a couple of steps down
and saying what is our version of
producing video it's similar to our
version of producing the news so it'll
be you know really fun things to watch
that help you kind of explore a topic or
get closer to a news event in a way
that's visual and really sort of worth
spending your time with so we're
starting to invest in that we've had a
lot of interest in video just
organically on the platform so in our
publishing platform you can very easily
embed video you know from any different
source something like a third to half of
our articles actually contain an
embedded video from another source so we
know there's a lot of appetite already
and now that there's also a chance of
doing this at a lower cost and as well
there's been ongoing demand from the
advertiser side for video inventory you
know all the pieces are kind of in play
for us finally to say
okay let's go out build up a video team
and kind of see what we can produce for
the readership that's really really
engaging really really exciting and
really really on brand for us which to
be fair took a bit of time to understand
and figure out and I think we have a
really similar approach to just the
macro context the opportunity is really
big you know in a lot of you are
probably working in the in the area
areas of media and technology that are
hoping to take advantage of the
over-the-top opportunities that this
sort of the the cracks in the in the
decades-old model of video entertainment
in in network television cable
television cable distribution that's all
like painting really has changed
dramatically over the last few years and
will continue to change news
organizations like ours actually that
that's an opportunity for for us as well
the second part of the opportunity is
that the platforms that readers are
using and Facebook in particular
snapchat also are are creating real
opportunities to distribute content via
if it is video and so there are rewards
for actually getting video right in the
short term on those platforms and the
longer term the potential of the sort of
remaking of video news and entertainment
is something that I think we presume to
have some opportunity to participate in
at some point so quartz is now about two
and a half years old we decided up until
two weeks ago effectively not to do any
video and there are three reasons first
we wanted to figure out who we were as a
brand as an editorial enterprise the
second thing is that there's so much
mediocre video it's you know things that
look like the three of us here you know
kind of on the on the web and and and
it's like it's hard to be proud of that
or feel that that's amazing journalism
whatever the quality of the conversation
is and then the and then it's also
actually really easy to lose money on
video because that the resources
required to actually produce video so I
just didn't feel like something we
wanted to get into so we know we've
hired three sort of video polymaths so
there are people who can edit produce
their journalists and they're
technically there have some animation
skills and we've created this kind of
laboratory of playing
with video and then publishing it
directly to Facebook and YouTube to try
and feel like what are the what do we
have conviction around as things that
that are really interesting
journalistically editorially and also
that people are willing to watch so
we've now published five videos and
we're going to kind of see how a five
videos in a week and a half and and
we're going to build from there and and
try and get conviction around things
that we then invest in further that's
sort of like the new triple threat for
journalists I guess is to be good a
video as well yeah so we've spent the
past half hour talking about how this is
a transformative time in journalism and
let's let's peer into the future now a
little bit what do you think will sort
of characterize the next phase of
journalism and what sort of tools do you
think a next-generation digital
publisher would need to have to be
successful yes so the thing I spent a
ton of time thinking about is just
distribution and that publisher reader
relationship I think that kind of as I
mentioned earlier there's been such an
impact to the content quality of content
because of kind of distribution coming
from channels like Facebook and snapchat
and all of these that kind of prescribe
a particular content quality or kind of
a reframing of existing content to fit
kind of a more mass appeal I think
there's going to be a little bit of a
correction against that I don't know how
that will manifest but I think that's
sort of something that I'm looking out
on the horizon it may take a little bit
longer than say you know like this year
but I think that's coming because I
think people care about quality doesn't
they care about real real conversation
in real stories the other piece is just
figuring out who will own distribution
for media every other industry has gone
through some kind of period of
fragmentation and consolidation around
specific distribution channels in media
is going through that right now so I'm
interested to see who the winners are I
think there's some early strong sort of
contenders but I think media is going to
go through a very similar evolution
where instead of maybe perhaps every
single media organization delivering
their content directly to the reader
there's going to be some sort of channel
some sort of intermediary a variety of
different access
I think that's happening and can't
really be changed but kind of have to
make a decision at whether you as a
media organization want to be sort of a
supplier of content to a variety of
different distribution channels or
whether you want to sort of somehow
build and manage and run your own in
addition to supplying others yeah I
think I'd agree i think there are two
parts of it on the journalistic side i
think we'll actually on the technical
platform side i think absolutely the
publishers who will succeed are the ones
who minimize the friction for their
content reaching its viewership or its
readership and this means that you make
it really easy for your content to be
for people to watch it on their internet
connected televisions or to access it
and share it via snapchat or wats that
whatsapp or whatever like just there are
technical ways including having a really
good on a very basic level having a
really good epi technically that allows
your content to spread is is sort of the
most important thing and I think
journalistically in there needs to be at
the core it needs to be quality content
and quality content but but a little bit
more creative and agnostic about the
form as we are not sitting down in our
breakfast tables holding newspapers for
45 minutes the actual way in which we
want to consume information has changed
we're more likely on our phone on the
run that might mean short articles I I
suspect my strong suspicion is that the
standard unit of production of
newspapers which is n news wires which
is a an article in the range of 800
words I'm I suspect that that will that
will fall away because readers are not
looking for those those are too
inefficient to consume there too long
the actual nuggets of information are
two buried in an unfocused article but
there's not enough pay off for you in
because you're willing to sit with your
phone or your computer and actually read
something long if you actually learn
something and enjoy the experience of
reading it so I think there's really
excellent excellent journalism going on
digitally now and and we're going to see
that more in ways that better match our
reading habits in a way that's actually
not less journalistic but in some ways
has the potential to
even more journalistic great um I think
we have a minute or two for questions
any questions thank you so this is this
is a study from Finland so the Finns
finished children are clearly not
totally media literate and they need
more education in that area the my
response that is that courts is an
independent news organization and we
have a reporter in London who found this
really interesting study about whether
people can tell the difference between
advertising and editorial content and
wrote it up our business model depends
on our business model depends on people
being able to tell the difference
between editorial content and
advertising and you know I guess there's
a debate over whether that's whether
that's uniformly true but I think it's
also a sign that you know we're not we
have a independent journalism that
actually is as exploring areas that
might actually be uncomfortable for us
where the people on our teams are out
selling advertising and in fact actually
those teams are probably ecstatic
because the advertiser is probably
really happy to know that consumers
think that their their advertisements or
similar articles by the way Victor's
question really touches upon another big
online journalism trend which is there
is an incredible incredibly refined art
and science to writing headlines
nowadays and both Gawker Media and
courts do do the headline writing very
well but anyway let's take more question
Kevin
startups on frozen these kings of the
audience they pitch stories to get their
their their cover website powered
what so so the thing that we felt we get
that question a lot because people don't
really totally know how to work with us
on the PR side so the magic answer is
we're really interested in data and so
as I said we are journalists created
3800 charts last year and some of them
were data sets that were supplied by
companies they were ultimately serving
those company's interests but were
actually the data was a way to shed a
light on interesting consumer behavior
or or business behaviour so a few
examples of that to two quick examples
that one is that there's there some
flight sort of travel companies that
have given us access to their flight
pricing data and so we have a kind of
data scientist who is crunched a lot of
this data and written a bunch of stories
about about trends in in ticket pricing
that you know we of course acknowledged
the company that supplied as the data we
make really nice charts that's a way to
actually get attention a second example
is we did a piece where a company called
ZocDoc supplied us with data about the
about doctors appointment bookings by
time of day and day of week and so we
just took this data and looked and wrote
an article that said if you want to if
you want to go to an uncrowded doctors
office for appointment or want to have
you know not have to sit around you
should book your doctor's appointment at
something like 11 a.m. on a friday or
something like that and the data the
data were pretty clear about that
someone told me that most doctors don't
work on fridays don't see patients on
friday so that may be part of it but the
answer to this is that we don't actually
write about product announcements we
really can't stand press releases there
are other news organizations but it will
do that our service to our reader is to
find out what's at the intersection of
what's important but also it's
interesting and the highest hit rate the
greatest success rate in pit is to us is
when someone comes to us with a data set
and
I have data that provide this insight
into how consumers behave or how a
market operates or how people live
around the world and we're you know I'm
not sure we've ever refuse any pitch
that that comes in along those lines
right there are all these new digital
storytelling formats and I think it
would probably be who any company
looking for publicity to think a little
bit outside the box in terms of you know
if you can offer something that's
data-driven or explanatory or something
you know a little different from sort of
a press release type article yes sorry
this we are
straight for your city
that's a cosmic question I think it's a
strength I mean I think it's awesome
that you know Facebook is a valley
company that survives on creating a way
to share and introduce people you know
and love and your community to things
that they should know and love as well
and the fact that media which is housed
in New York is a thing that people
should know and love is awesome I think
it's great that Facebook is finding ways
to integrate with communities that
aren't traditional sort of valley you
know kind of denizens I think that's
awesome this is totally a generalization
and I'll get in trouble for saying it
but I think a lot about again totally a
generalization but the valley is a lot
about technology for technology's sake
and I think New York is so much about
technology for the sake of industries
that need to evolve and grow and adapt
so you have things like fashion media
finance that are absolutely the center
of the universe New York is that place
for them and technology is coming here
and being applied to those industries
and really moving them forward and I
think Facebook recognizing that about
media is awesome I think it's totally a
benefit I think it's like good for the
media industry there's a concentration
of talent here that it's combining media
and technology that's that's really
pretty unparalleled and it's great for
companies like ours because we can
easily interact with and find people but
I think you're you know your point your
question is a bit more cosmic and I
think it's interesting to think about
what Silicon Valley is doing in another
area and that's the area of Finance so
you asked jamie dimon who the biggest
competitor Wall Street is and he has
repeatedly said it is Silicon Valley if
you talk to the entrepreneurs out there
in the bay area they are creating
alternative stock markets they are very
aggressively thinking about alternative
currencies regulation basically they're
there they're taking the financial
infrastructure that is much more East
Coast than west coast and they're
devising West Coast alternatives to the
system that they view is broken and
stuck in just kind of a hassle basically
and so that's their that's their sort of
view
the east coast on some level and it
probably would be really smart if you
know their equivalents in on the East
Coast sort of probably healthy to to do
a sort of equivalent to kick up an
equivalent sort of competition in areas
that the west coast is strong game but
maybe is is needs some competition all
right well I think we're out of time so
thanks for your smart questions and
thanks to Erin and Kevin